Anyways,
bins,
Wanger and boss.
So they work mostly in
the 1950s and as I said,
they were very concerned about
what had happened at World War Two.
And so Dostoyevsky and Nichi had basically
predicted that it was going to be
nihilism or ideological totalitarianism.
And that's basically
exactly what happened.
And by,
by the time the 1930s
appeared on the horizon,
the Germans had been,
you know,
they'd gone through an absolutely brutal
first world war and then they went
through hyperinflation
of insane proportion.
So in the 1920s Germany underwent this
partly because they had such heavy war
debts to pay for World War One.
The German German inflation got to the
point where it was literally upwards of
100 million marks to buy a loaf of bread,
you know,
so they were taking wheelbarrows
full of money to the grocery stores.
You know,
what happened was their
currency devalued to zero.
And you know,
that actually happens to economies
more often than you might think.
So the thing just hit
zero and that's that.
And then it has to be rebooted,
so to speak.
So they had been,
the war was dreadful in
hundreds of thousands of men
were killed or brutalized.
Then their economy just
absolutely fell apart.
And then of course,
at the same time,
well a little bit earlier,
the revolution had taken place in Russia,
right?
You know,
right at the end of the first world war
and the communists had come to power and
the communists were agitating all
over Europe and in North America.
And you know,
their goal was to,
to produce a communist
revolution that was worldwide.
And so the Germans were all shorted out
that the communists were going to take
over the country,
which was a perfectly reasonable fear.
And you know,
instead of that,
what happened was that fascism,
morose and fascism was a form of,
of state totalitarianism.
And I think the Germans were so
desperate for order by that point,
that,
and that's what the fascists
basically offered them,
at least in theory.
Um,
unfortunately as it turned out,
they offered them a little bit too much
order or maybe a lot too much order and
things went dreadfully south.
But then,
you know,
so then the whole world had to walk
through the horrors of World War Two.
And,
and it was shocking in a variety of ways,
not only because of the
brutality of the warfare,
but because of the genocidal actions
that took place consciously by the Nazis.
And you know,
and those actions were in many ways,
very difficult to understand,
um,
mean here's why they're particularly
difficult to understand.
There,
there were certainly times where the
brutality that the Nazis employed in their
eradication of their theoretical enemies
far surpassed the necessity for the
mere eradication.
But even worse than that,
so it went past eradication
into real torture constantly.
And not only that,
there are many situations
in which the Nazis,
especially near the end of the war,
they had to decide really whether they
were going to continue exterminating Jews
and Gypsies and homosexuals and all the
people they felt didn't fit into their
culture or whether they
were going to win the war.
And there were decisions they had to
make about the distribution of resources
where if they were going to pursue
the genocidal extermination,
that would mean it would decrease
the probability that they would win.
The war not happened a lot,
especially at the end,
and the Nazis always picked
continuing the extermination.
Now that's pretty damn interesting,
you know,
because you can think,
well,
on the one hand,
you know,
if,
if they are serving a creed and the
creed is world domination and this is the
extermination processes are considered
a step towards the actual end point,
which is the establishment of a
world state of fascist world state,
or at least a fascist European state,
then you would think that
the extermination attempts
would be subordinate to
that goal if they were actually pursuing
the goal that they said they were
pursuing.